wie bescheuert
herzlich sondern die leute nämlich heute
endlich mal wieder auf einer hilft mir
folge reagieren werde und zwar auf allen
der hilf mir klassiker folgen leute vier
millionen aufrufe mein sohn terrorisiert
die ganze familie
und ja hier sind wir hinten schon wir
haben heute verstärkung
was geht leute lasst uns den grenzstein
ziehen selbst einstellte und der hund
form der mitbewohnerin von der freundin
des bruders und ich uns jetzt sehr gute
haben schon oft über nacht dass man das
gemacht weil heute machen wie der
übernachtungs partie
und das haben wir sagt uns auf deine
meinung dass wir gleich sehen
so okay wir sind aber welche richtung
das ganze geht wir sehen hier einen
liebenswürdigen jungen mann der öfters
mal ein vorbildliches verhalten an den
tag gelegt indem er seinen eigenen vater
seinen eigenen erzeuger scheinbar
körperlich angreift da kannst dazu kann
ich an der stelle nur sagen
und dazu kann ich weil man der stelle
sagen hätte ich das mit meinem vater
gemacht wäre mein leben an dieser stelle
schon vorbei gewesen ja dann würdet ihr
das ganze jetzt nicht sehen
mein leben war so geisteskranken bei es
ist wirklich keinen job mehr die ja mein
leben war so hart vorbei gewesen alta
ripa gesagt heute was der film bastard
geht zu seinem vater der vater ist
einfach nur super liga immer okay das
ist dan essen ja ok und das aus so da
wären sie ein bisschen leiser wir wollen
wissen schlägt ihn fast zusammen ja
genau
typische reaktion typische reaktion
leute von einem vater in deutschland der
eigene sohn beleidigt ihn aufs übelste
gegen körperlich an droht ihm mit gewalt
wortwörtlich sonst haustier in die
fresse und der vaters ob man die
teenager von heute
nein nein so das ist nicht die realität
die realität ist dass ein kochtopf gegen
seinen kopf liegt
was kann man denn machen es ist wieder
komplett da haben wir treten heute sehr
schön dass das wollen wir doch
eigentlich sehen sie die tochter kommt
rein beschwert sich dass es zu laut ist
was macht sie sie der es zu laut ist in
diesem haushalt schreit erstmal ihr
anliegen nein wir sprechen es nicht wir
frühestens nicht wie sagen es nicht wir
schreien es bei uns ist es zu laut
die mutter hat schon einen hat schon ein
bluterguss im gesicht gesagt wird du da
da hat er soll einfach schon mal der
sohn schon mal zugelangt und die eltern
sind jetzt langsamer überlegen nach
diversen knochenbrüchen nach diversen
aufenthalten in der notaufnahme weil ihr
sohn sie kaputt geschlagen hat weil sie
ihm gesagt haben dass er den fernseher
bisschen leiser machen sollten sind sie
leicht überlegen was sie machen können
sind die eltern menschen oder sind das
wandelnde boxsäcke alter
übrigens leute falls es nicht wusste
diese folge wie die sagt 4 millionen
aufrufe ist mittlerweile eigentlich
schon so in den kammern der deutschen
lebens eingegangen soll heißen dieses er
wird euch eine sache sagen das ist
eigentlich schon richtiges deutsches
medium geworden aber kommen wir doch
kommen wir kurz zu der aussage von jedem
da er ist sowohl gegen den türrahmen
gelaufen
ja wir kennen die situation wollen
einfach mal unachtsam ist und einfach
mal mit der presse aber so kapital den
türrahmen rein sondern dass man einen
pferdekuss im ganzen gesicht hat
klassiker
[Musik]
das essen wünscht
kommt doch gerade der zeuge also selbst
wenn er so ein geisteskranker so ein
dreister sohn ist der sogar die grenze
zu gewalt seien einige eltern gegenüber
überschreitet aber er ist nicht blind
seine mutter bringt das essen in diesem
moment rein es so großes essen
genau das ist diese startete das ist
dieses einem ihm ja okay gut analysieren
wir uns gemacht bin finde ich persönlich
erst mal vernünftig nachdem er dann doch
sieht das auf den tellern die seiner
mutter ins zimmer rein bringt wider
erwarten doch essen es war essen ist
eigentlich selten auf teller in dem fall
war es doch da schlägt der natürlich den
teller oder das brett mit den liebevoll
gemachten großen aus der hand und
verlangt hühnchen mit reis
ich frage mich immer wieder warum solche
folgen so viele aufrufe machen also sie
zum beispiel vier millionen aufrufe und
ich glaube das hat in diesem fall
einfach was damit zu tun dass ich das
deutsche sky finden sich vorzustellen
wie oft sie von ihren eltern getötet
worden wären für diese aussagen die
ermordete
wieso habe ich das vorher nicht
verstanden wieso habe ich vor den
artikel komplett hängen oder wieso habe
ich voll nicht verstanden dass fitness
und muskelaufbau nur so geht bauch
aufpumpen jeder menschenfreund mal der
kraftwerk macht und studie will den
bauch auf
es ist gar keinen grund die leute aber
vor allem was ich falsch gemacht habe
ist das nicht von meiner mutter zu
verlangen die kann meine mutter hat
einfach ganz normal so normal nudeln
gekocht und so als ich noch zu hause
waren nach gepumpt haben ich hätte
einfach mal behindert schreiben müssen
und hühnchen mit reis verlangt hatte
doch gerade eben gesagt hat doch gerade
eben eine ausreichende rechtfertigung
für schwere und gefährliche
körperverletzung verletzung und mobbing
gegeben er kriegt hühnchen mit reis
nicht da finde ich sollte sie sich
nützen sollte sie jetzt hier nicht in
die opferrolle drängt sondern einfach
konstant wie eine geisteskranke jeden
tag wenig mit reis liefern
pascal da kennt keine grenzen auf der
einen seite ich kann es verstehen
auf der anderen seite kann ich nicht
mehr leute da da haben wir jetzt da
haben wir es heute ein kleines handbuch
für alle leute die in die
zugegebenermaßen extreme und auch
schwere situation kommen dass eine
elternteil wegläuft leute was macht man
dann genau man schlägt das verbleibende
elternteil behindert ich weiß ja dass
olaf recht hat wir leiden alle unter
pascal essverhalten und und dass er
dauernd geld für den boxclub das ist wir
haben sich eine gute story ausgedacht so
verlangt von seinen eltern geld für den
boxclub wofür brauche den boxclub leute
da schließt sich dem ich am ende wäre
der kreis er braucht den boxclub und
wiederum seine eltern noch behinderter
schlagen zu können
200 versteht ihr was ich meine leute das
ist eine richtig einfach ein großer
kreislauf kein kein teufelskreis seien
tuben kreis vernimmt das geld von seinen
eltern und die eltern noch härter
während mutter anne zur arbeit fährt er
lebt frührentner olaf eine böse
überraschung frühere endanleger heute
fakt der ist vielleicht 35 oder so da
hat er sich so entspannt wie man einfach
mit 35 in rente gehen sebastian 24
frührentner
die ganze kohle weg hier guck mal
einfach alles nämlich genommen was heißt
ja völlig ausgelaugt 100 euro ein
schluss dass mir viel mehr als 1000 euro
ja ja so ist es heute eigentlich
eigentlich müsste ihm viel mehr zeit
er sollte eigentlich froh sein das passt
kann an dieser stelle nur 400 euro aus
dem portemonnaie benommen hat pascal hat
nämlich die berechnung durchgeführt
leute herz eben mal ausgerechnet heute
erst ja intelligent ja nicht dumm sie
mir jetzt ein verhalten das er nicht
dumm ist ja und er hat sich schon
ausgerechnet 1000 euro hätte oder film
eigentlich geben müssen also lauf bitte
halt die fresse ganz ehrlich leute kann
hilft dass ich nicht mal eine geschichte
ausdenken die irgendwie auch mal sinn
nach die zumindest in sich stimmig ist
ja es ist geisteskrank wohnzimmer es uns
schlecht gespielt aber kann zumindest
die geschichte in sich irgendjemand
konsistent sein
die mutter sagt wenn er noch aggressiver
wird dann hat sie angst
aber da muss ja erstmal ein bisschen was
passiert also stand jetzt ist ja nicht
mal in lebensgefahr
durch ihren eigenen sohn also daher habe
ich auch keine angst haben sie wurde ja
nur schwer körperlich verletzt und warum
geht der tipp so aggro auf seine eltern
los aber seine schwester hat so gar
nicht also ich verlange jetzt nicht was
auch seine geschwister schlagen sollte
aber checkte was ich meine so wusste der
sinn
langsam langsam leute wenn dies nur ich
leider haben die irgendwie noch nicht so
ganz geht noch nicht so ganz den schuss
gehört dazu hause
was muss was muss passieren damit die
checken dass sie einen geisteskranken
haushalt leben haben was muss noch
gesagt haben was muss noch passieren
heute muss er mit einem sturmgewehr
reinmarschieren und auf sie schießen
damit die strecken so nicht was merkels
leute wenn er irgendwas im leben nicht
passt man irgendwelche irgendwie
geartete problem hat kann man gerne die
eigene familie als box hat benutzen weil
dafür kriegt man schon mal in
deutschland überhaupt keine strafen was
passiert überhaupt nicht ganz wichtig
für euch leute wenn ihr nicht wollt dass
pascal bei euch auch vorbeikommt und
verlangt dass ihm münchen mit reis macht
dann steht ihr unterhalt für euch
vorgestellt das video ab abonniert hier
oben kann
bis der strauß macht's gut